welcome back to new rock stars it's Eric
Watson Filipina here with the big
question it's our weekly Q&A show where
we're gonna dive deep into the questions
that really only nerds care that much
about but if you want to avoid pissing
off the Hulk you're gonna want to get
the answers to this one why is the Hulk
we're ready to be so bad it's like this
thing it's in his name it's this whole
thing so in this episode I'm going to
answer one big question that philip has
assigned me Phil's gonna answer three
bite-size question yeah and then once
the booze starts to kick in we'll answer
some fan mail questions does it start it
with like Philbin I just like getting
drunk getting hulk smashed we just
started rolling cameras and here we are
we built this set just drunkenly tearing
apart the room we were in
whoa let's get started okay this
question came from somebody on social
media his name's Sean Spaulding okay and
he wants to know and I thought this was
a great question actually what happens
if the Hulk collapse as hard as he can
as hard as he can and like like
specifically like considering that he
can do it kind of casually yeah you
could and you could do it like quickly
yeah exactly can do politely but full
Hulk strength I love this question
because I think we're talking about
hoaxes thunderclap right the thunderclap
is a move that he uses all the time in
the comics basically he just like
collapses hands together and it creates
like this sonic boom or this strong wind
and it makes an amazing sound effect in
the comics I saw whom I've seen cussed
room I've seen wolf there it is there's
the class and he likes smiles when he
does it he knocks people off their feet
it's been described as like a sonic boom
as a hurricane force in some cases it's
been deadly it's been known to kill
people that's how powerful it is but I'm
curious to know have we've seen this in
the MCU and the thing is in the Marvel
films it's not a very common thing I
think because it's like just we didn't
consider it just like a goofy move so we
never saw it in the first Avengers or
age of Ultron and Taika Waititi didn't
do it in thor ragnarok and in in
infinity war an endgame hulk hasn't
gotten a ton of big action scenes at
least where he's at a distance to be
able to use this movie yeah well also it
gets confusing is it wind or is it
percussive force I'll get to it I looked
into this
or so many no no we did see it one time
I don't think we ever saw Ruffalo hope
to it but we did see Ed Norton Hulk do
it in the first Incredible Hulk movie a
fire engulfs a helicopter crash
helicopter that Betty rust and thunder
but we're us are in and he gets away
from abomination he goes ah and the wind
or the the sonic boom puts out the fire
liquefies organs of everyone inside we
should have because here's the deal
normally wind even a strong wind fans
flames
whenever there's strong wind in LA it
causes fires to spread it does not put
out fires and if the jet fuel is still
hot enough as it would have been in that
moment it would just really it wouldn't
just like freeze the fire only if it
sucked the oxygen out of the room like
when you wear a beautiful dress and I
was gonna stop wearing them what he must
have done is create a kind of shock wave
and what a shock wave does is it's not
just like wind it displaces the air
molecules and they've actually
experimented with doing this to try to
put out forest fires University of New
South Wales has created like this tube
that blasts a pressurized air to
displace a flame off of its fuel source
thereby extinguishing it it basically
moves the fire Omega meter away from the
fish to by know how it works
in 2018 the Swedish Air Force didn't
know they had one dropped a 500-pound
bomb in the air above a forest fire you
we worked they bombed a forts fire to
put out the fire which sounds kind of
intuitive but it actually speaks to how
bombs really work it's not a fireball
when it explodes unless it hits like a
fuel source or a black powder charge
really all bombs are like pressurized
air that puts a blast out so like if
it's an AED it kicks up the dirt but
doesn't create flame unless it hits like
a fuel source now nuclear bombs are
different because they literally like
the air on fire in that case they cause
the air molecules to spread out so
quickly that speed causes an intense
thermonuclear blast that causes the air
and everything in the area to turn to
ash did the forest fire go out when they
did that it did it worked well but it's
too it's too risky because you're simply
dropping a bomb you don't know if you're
gonna kill wildlife in the area or
people who may be trying to put it out
it's a very risk like they didn't tell
the firefighters when will they ever
laugh but it's still concerned
experimental thing but a lot of people
are proposing using these kind of blasts
to put out wildfires instead of trying
to drop water over them which doesn't
always you need to kind of like still
the air essentially in order to to use
this so if we apply that to Hulk's
thunderclap putting out the fire what he
must have done was create a sonic boom
so what's a sonic boom sonic boom it's
when a moving object is moving so fast
the object suddenly breaks the sound
barrier and it's moving faster than the
speed of sound and it causes the air
molecules to be pushed aside so quickly
with such great force it forms a really
strong shockwave on a miniature scale we
see this with a crack of a whip right
like we see the whip crack and because
it happened so fast as a whiplash sound
it pressurizes the air so quickly it
makes us like snap a pop we've seen this
with like jet engines that fly too close
to the ground it's been known to shatter
glass if it applies too close to the
ground it's like a big boom people
describe it as like an earthquake
feeling it can rattle buildings in order
to create such a shockwave the decibel
level of such sonic boom would need to
be 195 decibels now that is loud enough
to rupture eardrums at a close range
roughly the distance Hulk was for Betty
who else now the thing about decibels is
they increase logarithmically so like
the difference between 195 decibels and
200 decibels is like huge
enough room just repertory in your
eardrums
to causing instant death so the way that
works is it ruptures your your lung
tissue and you choke on blood it's a
horrible horrible time so getting this
back to this moment in the comics hulks
claps as I said have been called a sonic
boom now these are comic book writers
don't know what that means a sonic boom
is 212 decibels thunder fun fact is that
215 decibels maybe that's why it's
called the thunderclap because it's like
being in a cloud of thunder and
lightning as it erupts if the sound
alone would kill you just because it's
so powerful the sound and it's like air
pressure
that's like rupturing your body tissue
in your blood and it just causes you to
die but the comics have also described
Hulk's thunderclap as being the force of
hurricane wind hurricanes are super
powerful if you were to condense them
all into a focused contents blast that
would be the loudest sound ever recorded
three hundred decibels which could melt
concrete melts that's how powerful if
you were to condense it all into one
focus blast because you think hurricanes
are spread out there like miles and
miles wide
that's like roughly at least double the
acoustic power of a nuclear bomb going
off so nuclear bombs turning to ash they
melt concrete that's how strong a
hurricane-force blast would people
clapped his hands if Hulk could
thunderclap the sonic boom to put out
the fire on the on the helicopter at
that range he also would have made Betty
Ross's and Thunderbolt Ross's ears bleed
maybe cause him to choke on blood yeah
which is not saving them at all that's
how powerful it is when he's too excited
but the fire but he put the fire out
right in that moment we shall also have
to assume that Hulk is berserk enough he
doesn't have control he's not doing a
golfclap he's not yet reached the point
of spaces and balance that Professor
Hulk is he's not wearing glasses he's
not wearing glasses not wearing clothes
except a elastic pants that never rip
and we're so jealous pants rip
constantly we'll find out about that
later initially he has no control over
exertion his he's clapping as hard as he
can also something that I want to dig
into we know that Hulk's strength
increases infinitely right and the
angrier he gets the stronger he gets
without limit he just gets more and more
powerful so the more he's hit the more
angrier
powerful he gets so if you think when
you clap your hands if you watch super
slow motion of hands clapping it's a
little dense between each of the meet of
your hands each hand it's like a sine
wave almost it goes I've been down and
your meet pushes back into each other
until it reaches tell me more about my
meet I'm gonna shove this in me like
this so imagine a little conflict going
on between Hulk's big hands when he
collapsed theoretically that could make
his hands he had angry or named matter
matter at each other creating a focused
a miniature heightened spike of power so
that this
thunderclap could have at least ruptured
their eardrums but also could be
powerful enough to create a hurricane
force level blast that could level a
city clear blast is Betty Ross should
have been like Sarah Connor in that
scene in t2 just a holding it's blown
off her bones that's what should have
happened in that moment because in the
comics Hulk has been known to get as
powerful to level cities to almost
destroy the entire United States with a
stomp he's been as powerful as being
called the world breaker Hulk where he
can turn planets to dust so yes if a
Hulk reached Willy thunder claps his
hands as hard as he can to answer your
question he could at least kill someone
instantly at worst level entire city it
sounds like even more theoretically if
you if his hand meets it continue to
piss each other off yes I like that I'm
also still picturing Edward Norton in
Fight Club where he's beating himself up
Hulk could do that to get stronger yeah
if he wanted to get powered up in a
moment to like a knock a building down
who should just keep hitting himself in
the face well have I proven to you why
they need to show the thunderclap in the
MCU I guess yeah I think just wind just
thought it looked goofy because it is
kind of a comics thing to be like aha
wind yeah well the wind version I think
is what's probably a little confusing
because we're imagining surface area
like sales rep creating and enough of a
Gus I did try to measure the size of
Hulk's hands on average but he you just
get bigger and bigger based on how
angrier he gets but in that moment where
a black widow baby was their hand across
his palm roughly I would say his hands
are roughly around three feet wide when
put together like
if you clap you know you're forming the
wingspan of like a gold eagle or a
California condor in that moment and
when they flap their wings they don't
knock people off their feet right even
unless they were to do it real fast and
I think we have to imagine that Hulk's
strength allows him to build up momentum
as he's clapping bird bones we feel like
we have bird bones after he collapsed at
us I didn't expect there to be so much
talk about like liquefying people but
that's great so if you're a Broadway
performer and Hulk's in the audience
just be very careful how much you commit
to the final number time for a break hey
guys Eric here just a reminder that new
rock stars is offering exclusive rewards
to our patrons in the form of bonus
videos each month for November I did an
in-depth breakdown of the opening
sequence of Raiders of the Lost Ark and
how it's so perfectly to find an A and a
Jones a hero and foreshadow to
everything to follow in that film
including Nazis heads exploding you can
get exclusive access to that video along
with lots of other behind-the-scenes
content and just a general good feeling
of helping this channel grow a becoming
an official patron of new rock stars
Digital Studios just go to
patreon.com/scishow stars again that's
patreon.com/lenguin
you trying to make me feel better at
major danger 11 asked why did Janet Van
Dyne age in the quantum realm when Scott
Lang stayed roughly the same age okay so
a lot of people brought the stuff as a
plot hole actually they're like how come
Janet says specifically I'm not the same
woman I was 30 years ago and she looks
30 years old still tight but 30 years
older she got the silver streaks and
then when Scott Lang goes in he has
skipped five years and it's been a
matter of minutes still very much
clueless Paul red yeah exactly it's like
he doesn't age what's most likely the
answer in the cannon is just based on
the concept of the time vortex right she
specifically says look out for time
vortices essentially right at the end of
ant-man and wasp and don't get sucked
into a time board
we won't be able to save you you do know
that's setting up and game the creators
of the film have confirmed that that is
the difference of the experience that
Scott Lang does he goes in there and he
does go through a time vortex even
though they didn't show it to us or like
yeah everybody got that right I don't
know that everybody did get that but he
went through a time vortex she did not
he skipped ahead five years she did not
she stayed there 30 years but I actually
think that there's a slightly more
interesting element to this question
where if you think about the fact that
Janet Van Dyne in the quantum realm
clearly lived a life in there right her
clothes are developed in a way where she
clearly has had access to a sewing
machine yeah but she also was involved
in the civilization that kind of sounds
like we multiple times pointed out that
city in the quantum realm under my
understanding I could imagine this city
is created in a space in the quantum
realm where time is kind of secured
within this bubble it's a safe place to
house her for people to live and live
normally outside of this bubble now
you're in the torrential storm of the
quantum realm where you know the
different sizes you are create that
relativity in time that Einstein
theorized any other area of the quantum
realm also might put you through time at
a different speed than a nice secure
safe place like that city that's
interesting yeah so outside of the city
there are these like holes they throw
that these ditches that you can fall
into that suck you through time right
and aside from those holes even just in
general the quantum realm is unstable in
terms of the linear time line okay I
like that answer
a treif underscore 98 said how does
Arthur Fleck fire eight shots from his
gun without reloading and this isn't
Joker yeah I remember this scene yeah
mistake mistake no it's not my points
actually so I did look into it anyway I
mean probably mistake right because we
see this in films like The Walking Dead
Rick is just from that finalist and
let's see yeah endless bullets
there is one interesting thing about
this film maybe it's not a mistake so
the gun he uses is a Colt detective
special the third generation of that gun
absolutely is a six shot gun so there
are some revolvers that they train old
people theorized maybe it was using an
eight-shot one no it specifically should
only be six that could be the mistake or
it could be just one more clue that this
sequence might be imagined we do know
that this is some very large spectacle
event that the news is covering to an
extent where everyone wants to know
who's killed these guys it's the whole
Thomas Wayne the fact that he actually
comes off as a villain it's because he's
sympathizing with kind of the wrong side
of the class warfare a very nice moment
and we do know that Joker's egomania is
putting him at the center of things
right he could he imagines he's goes on
Murray show and he's gonna be brought
down from the audience and he's gonna be
the star of the thing the idea that he
would be watching some Magnus on the
news and imagine that well what if it
was me that killed these guys which is
one of the scenes that is not confirmed
actually a hundred percent that he was
on that that killed them then that would
make sense that he actually doesn't
understand guns well enough to know how
many shots it would have he's
specifically when he's given the gun
earlier he says that he's supposed to
stay away from those things yeah he
clearly has been found to have mental
issues it wouldn't be surprising if
there is some sort of better background
check situation in Gotham than in the
real world where if you are an
established to be someone of a certain
mental state you're not allowed to get a
red flag laws exactly then he would not
have experience with these guns
so his guess is I don't know maybe has
eight shots maybe has Emilie's sure sure
it's like Fight Club like he's applying
his own understanding of how violence
works to his own life is imagine like
and then you can still even use this
argument even if he was the guy that
killed those guys then maybe just to the
last two shots weren't real yeah like he
walked up to and plugged it twenty Eyck
range a couple more times right so just
those extra like cool shots or something
maybe those weren't real but probably
just a mistake just a mistake we have a
question from Caleb Taylor in the
infinity war opening scene why does
Heimdall use
the Bifrost to save Hulk instead of Thor
okay so this question actually was my
favorite one of this batch there's kind
of a straightforward answer and then
there's a interesting comics lore answer
the most straightforward version of this
is that in this moment the Asgardians of
what's left of them are there Heimdall
is there
Hulk is there and Thanos and his peeps
are there in this moment Heimdall
decides I'm gonna send Hulk to earth as
a warning basically now the most simple
logic you can understand here is why
would he send Thor if Thor is the leader
and guardian of the Asgardians and
here's the potentially the final moment
of the Asgardians you don't take away
the warrior who's there to defend the
Asgardian and send him to earth and now
they're like great Hulk is here who
doesn't give a [ __ ] about us if you just
think it as simply as that Thor is an
Asgardian he protects those guardians
down with the ship basically and then
Hulk is an earth plane sent him to earth
right above all those people so that's
the easiest law to understand except
this is what I was thinking it was
really interesting about it you also
have to remember in that moment they're
not on Asgard they're not using the
traditional Bifrost bridge such a
situation this room that is established
that they've used multiple times in the
MCU in the comics the Bifrost bridge is
a big deal to channel that yeah and it
uses that dark magic the dark magic
actually is a destructive force that is
very hard to wield in the comics when
you send someone through it you actually
might kill them it's even Thor it's very
scary when you send him sucker that way
MCU hasn't really done it that way
except this is now not in that
controlled space where they designed it
to potentially even let you know Rocket
Raccoon uses that at one point so it
probably is like very safe when Hein
Bell straight-up says I'll father get
you know send the dark magic through me
one last time now we're talking about
the raw energy of this thing in this
version it actually might be just like
the comic version where he says that
exact same phrase there's not a lot of
entities that can withstand that so
Heimdall himself can though maybe it is
killing him and you know he's gonna die
anyway so it's fine
Hulk is one of the few creatures that
can probably also survive in this
straight-up dark magic flowing right
through him and Sonny interesting so
it's the difference of using a regulated
microwave in your kitchen versus using
plutonium to cook your genius
exactly yeah it works great but I do
have this tail now and it's pretty great
and you're riddled with tumors great
thank you so much for sending your
questions folks and keep sending those
questions at big question and now comes
the time to dig in
to get real guys we take fan questions
on this show yeah these are questions
that you guys send to our peel box and
then somebody sniffs them for whatever
powder you put on there and then get
real high then they pick which of them
we should answer on this show we got
spanked questions from you guys we
haven't seen these are you ready yes
I'll get through it happy cactus seven
asked have you ever been the victim of a
robbery or scam I remember you have an
identity stolen I'm sorry about that
yeah it was funny yeah when we first
moved to LA like 10 years ago we both
signed up for this Craigslist remember
this we sign up for a Craigslist no
audition I didn't go you told me about
it he said you might go and I'm like I'm
doing it it's one of these things that
you think is like a big deal and
apparently it's a rite of passage for a
lot of actors when you go to it is this
the office in like you know downtown
Hollywood which is not a good place
every place has nothing to do with the
movie industry yeah and you go to this
office and you realize it's you're in
this waiting room with a bunch of like
odd suckers like yourself you sit in
there and then you read from this weird
they call them sides but it's just this
like dumb ass monologue that doesn't
make any sense
and everyone gets like approved for it
and they tell you to call back at the
certain time to find out about when your
audition time is gonna be we find out
it's like auditioning for background
work cuz background work is just the
easiest thing to go to
there's no qualification you just show
up at a certain place in Burbank and you
line up and they'll be like okay you
just call this time and you show up and
you'll be in the background of NCIS and
you walk back and forth for an afternoon
and we get paid like 60 bucks it's
nothing but they make it seem like it's
this big deal to get this you get
featured in these TV shows and movies
and you don't know that it's for
background work but the way it's a scam
is that you have to go through their guy
to get your headshots to get your
consultation and all this stuff is the
way they fish new actors stand there
pretending essentially that they your
representation that they've got your
manager yeah and you do not need
absolutely not anybody could do it
oh six years do you suffered those yes I
did once I I realized what was up I I
blogged about it I think an oh I'm gonna
blow the lid wider than this because the
person who owns his company you and I
did some research
it's this weird sound a dude named
Emperor Frederick von Seidel or
something like that I blogged his name
whoever this guy is commented on the
blog defending his company and I called
you I'm like am I gonna get sued if
information and like I'm not a lawyer
but no yeah I got a ton of on my blog at
the time it was like my most viewed
think is a ton of people anytime to try
to google this guy his name is it
doesn't show up anywhere except on my
blog but I think it's still around we
don't know what the name of the company
is it's probably run by the
Scientologists because I think it was in
a Scientology was intelligible yeah yeah
and they have like Emperor's right sure
yeah yeah I got robbed once as a kid I
don't know that I need to share that I
think you do I got robbed as a child
like such a terrible it was the middle
of the night my siblings were out
because he's to go out they would stay
out all night they were there were bad
kids and our apartment we actually all
three of us all my siblings shared the
same bedroom but but they were out my
parents were like on kind of the far end
of the apartment and our room was right
up by the front of the house I kind of
had like insomnia as a kid really bad
they'd be waiting up for my siblings and
it was maybe like 3 or 4 a.m. and I had
just turned off Nick and night watching
tactic VanDyke or something I was trying
to go to sleep and then I heard the
sound of what essentially was my my
siblings coming home or I thought it was
you know opening the door and then
opening the bedroom door and I figured
well I'm sleeping in my brother's bed
the bigger bunk so I'm just gonna
pretend I'm asleep here cuz otherwise
it's gonna make me go to my book then I
realized neither of these voices are my
brother and my sister but they're
whispering and they're kind of like I
can tell they're starting to go through
stuff and they end up for like 15
minutes ransacking the whole room going
through everything I'm not I'm not
looking at any of this because I've
since realized holy [ __ ] these people
are robbed
platon how old are you I'm maybe nine
years old maybe maybe ten okay and then
I remember the last thing the area they
do is they do the closet which has like
the loudest door and it's big creek it's
like all right like hugely loud but I'm
still here pretending I'm asleep in the
same room they go through the closet
completely they come back out and then
it seems like they're on their way out
the route out of the room and then one
of them is so ridiculous one of them
leans down right over me as I'm
pretending I'm asleep and I can toms
shaking like very violently and he just
laughs and he was uh this kid thinks
that we think he's sleeping and and so
of course I just like [ __ ] myself
immediately I know he just like made it
so much worse and then they leave and
then I sit there for like maybe an hour
and a half or two hours just frozen for
like making sure that they're gone and
then and then I get up I run to the
kitchen and I get a knife just like a
butter knife or something okay whatever
I can wield and I like scour the house
and early apartment and there there's no
one there and then I cried to my mom and
yeah Rabia to pick up a knife at that
point but missive right up now I was
thinking my ending it I thought that did
knowing that this evil exists in the
world for a man to say this to a young
boy sleeping but because I'm sleepy
knowing that he can hear you I never
opened my eyes so maybe this is a coping
mechanism but for me it's like Marvin
Joe Pesci it's like just the home alone
robbers like the sticky bandits yeah but
it would be like Joe Pesci knowing that
Macaulay Culkin can see his reflection
in the Norn iment and just smiling like
that's the evil and it's like terrifying
and and have you gotten over this thank
you for sure oh I mean it like I don't
know probably scarred me in a bunch of
ways but I think made me slightly more
interesting a person by the end what a
story
oh my god that's a fun one yeah that was
common to Danny rolling we visited your
bed yeah well now that I didn't think he
was a murderer but now I do
god I gotta go to therapy again at Tech
St Mirren as how'd you guys get started
like who met who first we're one okay
when Philip was a boy it's nothing
[Music]
what is our origin story I feel like
there's a couple different or getting
started is different than like new rock
star yeah we met in in college doing
improv at University of Florida and we
were both part of the same like improv
cult
it was a cult yeah we're both the
records difficult many of the people who
work here at new rock stars off-screen
producer and other producers producers
they're all from the same cult but like
a specific story that I think like I
auditioned to be part of one of the
house ensemble long form teams and then
I went home and I blogged about it I
might have like mentioned view in the
blog and I spelled your name wrong you
made a joke that was related to Alfred
Molina right people are getting an
indication of how much you used to blog
I think I scoured them all from the
internet they aren't there scrub them I
do remember distinctly the first
conversation we had I was in like one of
the food courts I had just like applied
to be the like a staff writer an
editorial blogger for the newspaper and
they denied my application but then
there was another guy who did who they
accepted and I was like talking [ __ ]
about his like opinion piece and then I
was complaining about it to you because
you knew me from TSS I was a complete
stranger yeah you walked up you're like
hey yeah I saw your blog and you're like
I applied to be part of it too and
they're like yeah those alligator
writers guy sports column yeah and they
did not run that yeah so we commiserate
it over being rejected yeah there's more
to this story I think but we got eat get
out you gotta keep asking pradhan
there's that time that you punch me in
the face that was that yeah and then at
Holland Holland totes totes EXO asked
have you ever had an awkward interaction
with the celebrity oh so yeah when
you're when you live in LA this sounds
like like a humble brag or something but
like you do run into them a lot that
like to pull a yeah they live here like
continues with actually yeah I saw
Randall Park in front of me at a
Starbucks and he looked at me in smiles
yeah I feel like I'll have a different
story but but right now the only one
that's coming to mind is uh recently I
got to interview Ralph Macchio oh yeah
yeah he brought his own a hair and
makeup guy that he's been working with
forever and this guy's
for some reason is literally Bruce Wayne
but then they also wouldn't let us see
his ID okay well neither would Bruce
Wayne and the guy like he like kind of
looked at me and I guess he kind of he's
been working with Ralph for so long that
he just decided that he needed to do the
exact same hair and makeup to me that he
was doing to Ralph for interview except
like he kind of paints Ralph like in
this kind of Sicilian way that is you
know the look that you're familiar with
Ralph Macchio but Roth watches is
actually a much paler than than he seems
yeah and so he then just turned to me
and did the exact same thing to me and
the footage is unusable because I tried
to make me look like him and we both
like are sitting at wheat and it doesn't
look great but I look like I'm in
blackface oh my gosh so we can't include
an insert of this no we can you can
imagine it yeah I mean I can literally
never run for office I have had a couple
awkward encounters with celebrities I
used to work on a talk show where that
kind of desensitize made of famous
people because you see them come in and
out the door every day but we shared an
office building with like people on
other shows and right above us was
Brooklyn nine-nine which is like my
favorite show at the time and I get the
elevator opens right in front of my desk
and I'm on my way out to lunch and it
opens and I see what I think is my
friend Anna on my sketch team at the
time and I go hey cuz I wasn't expecting
to see her and I give her a big hug no
she goes hey and hugs me back and as
soon as I'm hugging her I realized this
is not Anna
there's crews waited see in the elevator
not to agree that it's Michelle for
marrow the place Santiago and Brooklyn
release and I'm like mmm
and she just hugs me because she assumes
that she's supposed to know who I am and
I realized and I just go so how's it
going today
busy busy and we just make small talk I
think she just assumed that she was
supposed to remember who I was
she probably assumed we were like some
writers writer or someone who worked on
a previous show of hers or just some old
friend and like we wait for that
elevator is the longest elevator ride in
my life as I realized I was not best
friends with Michelle from arrow but for
that moment for a brief second as we
hugged
we were just ever see her again are they
told you I saw her around but I would
avoid you know that same elevator would
take
stairs this has been the flan we got
some questions answered and some
memories
retriggered oh you know why I am the way
I am now you always mail us our fan mail
at the thing that is our loard appeal
Bobbio box and thank you to everyone who
sent in two questions keep those
questions coming at new rock stars
hashtag big big question we are getting
be resolutely more drunk as the show
goes this is why you can't blame them
that's right
and you can follow us on social media a
da vas at Villa Molina and you can
follow the wrestlers at new Rockstar
subscribe to new rock stars here on
YouTube thank you so much for joining us
see you next week bye bye
[Music]